here with reaction wisconsin senator ron
johnson is with us senator you know we
have confirmed on this show that there
are over 20 fbi whistleblowers you know
of many of them
um we now know the fbi has been
politicized it seems like the doj has
been weaponized my question to you is
there are reports out that these
whistleblowers
believe that director ray has lost
control of the bureau are you hearing
that
not specifically that but i first have
to comment on what's happening in
memphis it's horrific my thoughts and
prayers go out to folks there but you
know sean you mentioned a duel or
two-tier justice system i'm calling at
least three three-tiered and you have
the one system that
treats hillary clinton and hunter biden
with kid gloves then you have the one
for you know most other americans but
then you have the weaponization of not
only the federal law enforcement the
justice department but federal agencies
like like the irs like osha they come
after the democrats political opponents
and that one you know again that is very
corrosive to our democracy and we're
seeing that
play out time and time again what we're
hearing from whistleblowers and god
bless them for coming forward you've got
people of integrity within these
agencies that uh want their agencies
restored to uh you know have a
credibility integrity so they're coming
forward that they're starting to talk
about what they're seeing and that's the
only way we're going to restore
integrity
we need to understand the truth
they got a reminder from the attorney
general that they're not allowed to talk
to elected officials to senators to
congressmen and women
is that your understanding because that
sounds sounds an awful lot like
intimidation to me what are your
thoughts
no i i don't understand how the attorney
general can issue such an order
people who work for the federal
government have the absolute right to
come forward to congress and be afforded
whistleblower protection and so again i
am calling on people not just in the fbi
not just the department of justice but
if if you are concerned about what is
happening your agency the politicization
of it it being weaponized against
american citizens come talk to us we'll
afford you that whistleblower protection
because again that's the only way we're
going to restore confidence in these
agencies we need to expose the truth and
that's pretty much my mission
you know senator i've been watching your
campaign and
according to some estimates
there have been 50 million dollars
already spent on negative ads attacking
you a lot of that money coming from
outside of wisconsin
one of the big lies that they're telling
is that you want to cut back on social
security benefits and medicare benefits
it's uh it's not true
but i want to give you a chance to
respond and what do you know about your
opponent barnes that america would need
to know and that the people of wisconsin
need to know
well first of all that is probably the
biggest of many lies let me just think
of it for a moment sean what elected
official would ever propose cutting or
ending social security it's absurd on
its face i want to save social security
but what what wisconsinites need to know
about mandela barnes is he's a radical
leftist
he's a guy who thinks that the founding
of america was awful he thinks national
parks are racist you know what's racist
about old faithful
he supports all of the radical policies
of the body administration that's
causing so much pain for wisconsinites
you know 40 year high inflation record
gas prices rising crime the open border
flooding our states with deadly drugs
killing our citizens so again he
supports all of those things but he's in
hiding sean
uh he will not answer questions from the
press he wants to pull the wool out over
wisconsinites eyes while he's lying
smearing lying about me smearing about
me
assassinating my character and engaging
the politics personal instruction but
that's all he has he he can't defend
democratic policies and he can't defend
his past positions on these issues
same issue going on in states like
georgia
we'll talk to hershel walker states like
pennsylvania with dr oz this guy
fetterman has campaigned for a whopping
20 minutes the entire general election
you can't make it up
your race is important we're going to
continue to monitor and we thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else